hello Nick good to see you
congratulations how are you I am
obsessed with you like your movies
ruined my life because I keep getting
these movies from you that I obsessively
watch over and over and over and then I
don't watch the other movies that I have
to for work haha it's working perfect
yeah yeah thanks John very well done
um to tease what Tyler is all about for
people who haven't seen the menu just
yet can you tell me what your favorite
and least favorite quality of his is you
know a part of him that maybe you admire
a little and then also something about
him that people should keep an eye out
for as things get crazier and crazier in
the film I think that's a tricky one
because the things that I admire and
hate about them are also that so close
together and entwined there's this you
know the tragic elements of IMO this
um his desperation to be accepted and
how uncomfortable he is in his skin and
just to kind of feel wanted I suppose
um and then and then there's this real
pretentious kind of know-it-all manage
display any side of him that's kind of
horrific as well so there's there's lots
of fun to be had I guess one of the
things that is kind of endearing about
him is his passion and love of food yeah
I I pose a similar question to Hong and
it seems like this is a group of people
where you know often their best quality
winds up becoming a terrible
double-edged sword yeah yeah completely
all right so this set basically sounds
like the ultimate acting Master Class to
me with the way you shot this film so
while you were doing your scenes is
there anything that you saw a menu
co-star do that I don't know either
either wow you or made you think I gotta
back pocket that technique and I gotta
try it on my next movie oh I don't know
if there was technique things where I
was like oh but you know what I loved
watching John Leguizamo and Amy
carrero's takes because they they're
improvisational skills was so impressive
and so funny they would just be like
they were just it was like they would
just been Unleashed on a scene and and
the originality of what they were coming
up with in the dynamic between those
characters really really fun but I mean
each table had so many wonderful
elements and Brilliant actors that it
was it really was like a joy when you
knew that the camera wasn't on you and
you could just purely watch and enjoy
um what was happening all right I'll ask
uh specifically about Anya now because
you guys share quite the dynamic in the
film what is it about her that you
appreciated as a scene partner the most
that you know maybe even brought
something out of you that you wouldn't
have been able to access without her oh
I mean Anya's such an incredible actress
in terms of her authenticity in every
moment but also being very open and
giving to to you as a as a a scene
partner so you kind of get this ability
to to try things and run with things and
and then and feel completely like you're
in the moment together I think one of
the really fun things about our dynamic
in this relate in this relationship in
the film is that we have
for all intents and purposes a surface
level of this relationship that you
watch as the audience and you kind of
think that perhaps they're a normal
couple and then there's gradual little
hints and clues as you go that perhaps
things are not what they seem and that
was really fun for us to play because
it's kind of how much of a hint can you
give to the audience while still keeping
it in the right realm and then also for
Andy's character she's giving a
performance within a performance of who
she is so it was really fun to watch the
veil occasionally drop for a split
second and then and then appear again
and that was just you know incredible
that thing to to witness it's an
impossible movie to talk about I'm just
like bursting at the seams wanting to go
a little too far uh to keep us well
clear of spoiler territory I wanted to
go back to the The Improv is there any
example that you could remember from
filming of another actor who threw kind
of an unexpected curveball at you and
you had a run with it and the scene
turned out better off for it I think one
of the key moments that was always fun
is there's a there's a beat in the film
later on for my character when Rafe
Whispers in my ear and Rafa was always
Whispering something different and I
won't say what they were but it was
always exciting because there was always
an anticipation from my side of things
of what he was going to say and how that
would affect me so that was also just
yeah a fun moment all right I guess I'm
like silly very silly random food
questions for you so for the first one
on my little list here is what's your
most controversial food opinion uh I
don't know if this is controversial I
just don't like Anna seed flavors and
like Licorice and stuff
um so take that and yeah do what you
want with it if that's controversial I'm
with you on that yeah I don't care what
people think of me I don't like licorice
I don't either what what food do you
have the most of at home right now
uh what food do I have the most of right
now uh you know what uh uh bread
that's the right answer there's a
certain scene in this movie that felt
like it was speaking directly to me and
it stressed me out
you can only use one condiment for the
rest of your life which condiment do you
pick and why this is very difficult
because I do like condiments
um you know what I've recently been
putting a lot of Japanese barbecue sauce
on things and I'm happy about it and I'm
excited about where it's taken my life
okay I think I'm gonna have to go buy
some of that now can you name a kitchen
appliance that you own but have no idea
how to use
oh uh no I think all I think all the
things I've
got I know how to use I don't really
have that many crazy appliances though
uh no sorry
that question was more for me who knows
how to use basically nothing in the
kitchen
um this is more character specific but
what do you think Tyler's favorite food
is that he would be embarrassed to admit
to Chef slowik
oh well you know what I think that's
interesting because actually I think the
thing with Chef slowik the thing that
takes him back to his happiest moment is
this idea of just creating a great
cheeseburger and I'm sure there's
something with Tyler as well where he's
probably
someone who suppresses painful childhood
stories and I and I had this whole idea
with him that he was actually probably
punished somewhat with food by his
parents at certain points and has then
grown to love it again so there's
probably some some uh emotional uh
qualities of his childhood that are
wrapped up with things
um yeah yeah oh that's so heartbreaking
let me answer your question now I want a
whole prequel about his story
before they kick me out of here I have
to ask one question about Nosferatu
because I've been looking forward to
that movie for a long time and I was
revisiting an interview I had done with
uh Robert back in 2016 when the witch
first came out and when I asked him
about it he flat out said that that
movie is a masterpiece and that it
doesn't really need to be redone so now
that you're actually gearing up to make
it what is it that's convincing you
about his script that yes this movie is
something that is necessary to redo
right now well it's I mean I am a fan of
the original but I think knowing
Robert's work and knowing that he's
wanted to make this film and tell this
story I think he's been obsessed with it
since he was about eight years old he
told me so when it means that much to
him personally and knowing what he's
created with the northmen the lighthouse
and the witch I'm like his version of
that story was something that I as a fan
would be excited to see so to get to go
make it with him it's something I'm
really looking forward to I feel like
you're gonna get the reverse question a
lot today but did Anya give you any
advice for working on a robber Eggers
said you know what she she said it was
the most incredible thing because he
Demands a lot of you but he's also
capable of pulling those things out of
you as a performer
um at the end of the day when you go
home you feel very satisfied and like
the fact that you've you've hopefully
given something special and there's
nothing worse than finishing a day and
going home and being like ah could I
have that little niggling feeling of
like could I have done something better
could I have brought more to that so I'm
looking forward to him really pushing me
and demanding a lot oh my what a lovely
answer I cannot wait to see that but in
the meantime I will be watching the menu
over and over and over again so thank
you for yet another one of those and
huge congratulations okay thank you so
much